in one of the videos that blew up the most on my page,
I spoke about how you can be regarded as a high
value woman
and you can be regarded as a divine feminine woman
even if you don't have money
or a certain physical appearance.
and although physical appearance matter to an extent,
because obviously you have to take care of yourself,
here are 5 principles that will signal to other people
and to yourself that you are a high value woman
and you will be treated as such.
one. she is able to blend in in any circumstance.
one day she may be rich,
she may be up here,
one day she may be poor and sleeping on the couch,
but either way
she is able to do with her circumstance with Grace.
she is able to adapt,
be flexible,
blend in, and be happy and grateful
in any situation you put her in.
not only is she able to adapt though
any situation you put her in,
she is resourceful enough and smart enough
that she can make the most out of it.
that is why she is highly desirable with everyone,
because no matter who it is,
she can start a conversation with them.
a high value woman is in only all high status.
if that were the case,
that person would be entitled.
trait number 2 is that she values sisterhood.
it doesn't matter how much drama there is in the world.
a high value woman understands the core integrity
of what having female friendships is.
because at the end of the day,
if you're a woman,
why would you not identify yourself with other women?
it doesn't make sense.
a high value woman
understands the role that she plays in with other women.
I don't want to run out of time,
so I'll just make a 3 part series
and you can check my page to know the other ones.